à perte de vue un champ d'orge brassière
la moisson ne peut pas attendre depuis
une semaine
clément mercier est à bord de sa
moissonneuse 12 heures par jour
une course contre la montre est lancée
il faut prendre de vitesse le temps
après une météo capricieuse
on a pris 50 millimètres d'eau nous cinq
jours avant la moisson
donc ça pose des problématiques d'une
bas pour démarrer la boisson tout
simplement puisqu'il nous faut une
certaine humidité pour pour stocker le
grain donc on était obligés d'attendre
que sar sèche malgré la maturité du
grain qu'ils étaient prêts à récolter
pas le temps de faire une pause à la
tête d'une exploitation familiale de 205
ha le ciré est né à diversifier ses
cultures ne pas mettre tous les oeufs
dans le même panier
la priorité c'est l'orge parce que
justement elle est plus sensible à la
verse
elle est déjà un peu coucher et donc du
coup on veut pas qu'il pleuve dessus
alors que le blé pour l'instant est chez
nous pas couché donc du coup il est
moins sensible à cet effet pluie qui
pourrait arriver la moisson bat son
plein et la remorque se remplit à vue
d'oeil
désormais se pose une question quelle
quantité
or quelle qualité et la quantité à
l'erreur relativement la cie une année
moyenne voire base mais c'est pas non
plus une catastrophe comme 2007 par
exemple mais en tout cas pas chez moi
les prix sont un peu plus élevés que
peut parfois donc ça peut compenser une
petite partie 2
d'un manque de quantité parfois mais ça
fait pas tout non plus moi j'ai plutôt
le sourire en général mais
pour l'instant pas unique la moyenne
donc ça va c'est pas donc les
je sais pas catastrophique quoi voilà le
jeune chef d'entreprise de 27 ans
gardent le sourire mais scrutent le ciel
commencé en milieu de matinée sa
rotation ne s'arrêtera pas avant 23
heures